ipagamine hypergamy is that women want  to date are constantly trying to date up  no no no no wait wait wait wait wait  wait wait wait women are constantly  trying to date up they're trying to get  trying to get the best deal that they  can get men men will get a deal and be  like you know what I'm actually quite  happy with this and hang on let me  finish men will get a deal they will get  a woman who's a six out of ten that she  ticks all the boxes and they will Coast  for the rest of their life wait wait  wait  so women are always looking for that  level up right which is why which is why  if I was to ask all of you women here  right now the types of men that you want  you would probably list a man in the top  20 of men